CROWD: (CHANTING)
Rel, Rel, Rel!
LIL REL HOWERY:
I'm from the west side
of Chicago.
I used to walk
up and down this street.
Seeing my name
on this building is insane.
-Damn right,
you should clap for that!
-(LAUGHTER)
Let's go!
I love being in my little
grown-ass relationship.
I'm not trying to be
with no young motherfuckers.
Too much energy.
One of my homeboys has a girl,
she's, like, 25.
Every time I see him,
he's tired!
When we went on a double date,
she was like,
"Yeah, we went to karaoke
on Monday,
Tuesday, we did this,
we went to Tulum
on Wednesday."
(LAUGHTER)
That nigga just sitting there
like this...
(LAUGHTER)
"Left the job, went to Tulum,
right after work,
went to the airport,
right after work."
These pastors are losing
their fucking minds.
Watching the old nigga
that talkin' about Beyonce.
"She worships the devil!"
That's what he said.
He said, "She got all that
goddamn money,
that is the results."
(LAUGHTER)
You dumb motherfucker,
you just promoted the devil.
(LAUGHTER)
CROWD: (CHANTING)
Rel, Rel, Rel, Rel!
(CHEERING, APPLAUSE)